bene tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo non bisogna un gas ma oggi faremo
una roba molto strana più nella lotta
scorsa praticamente ci giocheremo le
partite speed date cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che hai pochissimo tempo per fare
tutto ci sono tipo tre tasche però se
velocissimo l'impostore a un il time che
che vi di pochissimo tempo quindi puoi
ammazzare molto velocemente
e tutto molto figo però è tutto molto
veloce e frenetico spero mi piace perché
una versione un po particolare ma
godetevi la buona visione
è la partita da che rumbe e cha un
cappello di energica per ogni natale
tranne nat e io che ora però la
spacciatore abbiamo solo 15 secondi per
dire le nostre cose questa cosa è molto
divertente
i killer hanno un call da molto veloce e
noi andiamo veloce tutto veloce tutto
sfidato questa è la partita di among us
sfidata vediamo quanto riusciamo a fare
nico punto vorrei uccidermi mica non mi
uccide nemico punto grandissimo
io vorrei che noi erezione il cadavere
di nati il web
lì vicino c'era la cosa non ti difendi
pensa se ci aveva azzeccato così ma dove
siamo bravissimi
la sfida siamo siamo bravissimi a fare
le cose velocità chiudano cercare sempre
così
che noia che sta lì a non fare
assolutamente niente e che noia che noia
che noia che noia che noia
f qua se fai qua lo vedo vedo vedo ti
vedo step di vedo non ti lascerò morire
ma ti lascerò morire
no lo so matteo fire era lì è stato se
da sempre che è stato lì
materiali anche da prima che io stesso
non siamo noi a pila di filateliche che
noia che noia
me lo sento dentro come vedo che noi ha
scavato un puledro eccola che noia che
io aiuto c'è un corpo ok ti ronca
davvero davanti a ossigeno era davanti
alle telecamere ragazzi o bravissimi a
[Risate]
caricare raga perfetti madonna ragazzi
adesso sono impostore io e la cosa è
molto e medicine poteva che anche faccio
è il tutto velocissimo matteo fire è
l'unico da solo qui lo ammazzo qui lo
ammazzo lomazzo l'ammazzano marzo a meno
che non vada giovane giovanni bogliolo è
perfetto non ammazza niente ma centrato
kent che non è un impostore cosa vedo
come fa apple come possibile fatto fuori
maiocco via via via venta verità
lentamente a documenta mentale sono il
tratto di sora le luci c'era il viola
morto e non so dieci anni franco e mario
non lo so ragazzi era neanche lì e
quindi cosa
cosa facciamo niente
come faccio a vincere non si può vincere
sabatino ragazzi nella provincia e così
c'è la troppo veloce sono anche è stato
bravo ma nonostante questo va troppo
veloce la partita io come posso fare
anche solo pensare di fare una roba del
genere matteo files aqua festa qualche
fanno le tasche attenzione aiutatemi
dice che telecamera fila non c'e nessuno
ma era marci
ma va a cagare o ci sono marci
invisibile o ucciso march che era in
magari le belle attrazioni macori di
marzo è morto
non ero rientrato in mezzo un caricatore
ci sono adesso abbiamo scriviamo siamo
ma ci sta io ho ucciso uno invisibile ed
era invisibile la cosa picks live che
non c'è o meno male che era loro mamma
mia
perfetto che curò chiara è morta fare
bene e razzola male ma la chiamava data
che noi gli allocchi siede a mente
siamo salvi ne manca una deve ancora
fare i bravi lo stacca primaria e la v
raga è morto loco dove votare loco per
forza e se non mi avrebbero incolpato è
l'unico dalmazzo che noi arm e vado tix
light peak lei sta fare certi xlite c'è
la pixar e la luce vediamo cercare
qualcuno a the fire vinto già grande
faglia mamma mia ragazzi
a me va bene
tu eri invisibile the ucciso che il
visibile ma cosa che casino lui si
capisce più nulla di quello che succede
ma quanto per qualche video è peraltro è
veramente non esco mai il posto ora il
posto mai uscire il posto report del
demonio quando c'è la sfida che io
veramente non ho parole per noia che
noia mazzoni rai che è venuto a fare la
mazzoni dai che noi abbiamo è morto
studente ma dopo a rischio da un match
perfetto siamo velocissimi nat che è
andato giù 5 4 3 2 1 e bello che c'è lei
il condom belo velocissimi quindi anche
figo ok me lo avevano riportato il match
in diretta che avevo visto nessuno parla
di canale se ne sono ma ho visto uscire
da me non era invece tu sei entrato che
sono già dati made by mai mi sa di no
novate tempo ti vedrò capito tipo io
sono morto io ho azzeccato con sbagliati
sia patrimonio nell'anima sbaglia e si
ma non era lì corpo che chiusa centro
porta del demonio mai di perdere per una
cosa sbagliatissima maledizione che
sfiga totale io non ho votato
il motivo niente sono morto per culo
loro perché non mi hanno beccato
semplicemente fra carlo la vecchia
chiesa istia natale cosa sbagliatissima
e mi hanno buttato fuori va beh ma ci
sta ci sta dopo due partite così io cosa
devo fare faccio le tasche chi è che sta
giocando a fare devo seguire fare voi
potete fare che cosa fa
si può fare viper e ma cosa c'è in testa
poi io ti metto elettrica anzi non posso
metterlo che dai messo già 30 le tenaci
che le perdo addirittura la gente non
vedono anche due eccola qua che partite
energizzanti inserisce una sega by fair
viper allora è bravo che la perfetto
bravo però proprio marci
che peccato difenditi almeno era
sbagliata
era una cosa sbagliatissima ci avete
avuto un culo io non ho fatto niente ma
incollato sbarcato vincolato a caso ai
ragazzi questa è la bisogna jia con
piazze spesi è piaciuto anche perché a
me sono piaciuto un sacco sebbene mi
piace un sacco fareste partite tutte
però se papa può sapere se volete ancora
episodi del genere perché secondo me
molto figo questa versione invece
ragazzi si chiede al canale lasciate un
bel commento questo 8 su cosa vorreste
vedere le possibilità di applicare o in
generale questi video che non è che c'è
sola magari ci vediamo come sempre a un
passo vinto ben ragazzi
[Musica]